hey guys this is victoria and i'm here
with my very special waifu hey it's
vampy it's fancy yeah we have this
one-of-a-kind never will be made again
ever ever because we're gonna bring it's
a crunchy roll ps3 and you guys can win
it um yeah you can win his way but it's
not gonna be that easy you have to
record yourself doing some of the
craziest craziest stuff dress up as a
crunchyroll mascot cartwheels or
something with crazy paint on yourself
skydiving through a bunch of a legate
run through the aisles of like Walmart
or something screaming criteria yep in
your car order to crunch your mom's car
and prove it oh well of course make a
crunch roll spirit day or high school
videotape yourself a long way I put my
kid in jail because he paid in my car to
scream crunch we want you to do
something documented showing your love
for crunch roll it needs to be crazy
passion crazy oh she's trying to say
because you think it this is only fun so
the only way you can win it is doing
something crazy showing your love for
crunch because we can only pick one
person yes so you have to blow the
competition out of the water you cannot
link us to your YouTube video here in
this thread and sailor being myself and
baby baby will choose winners at the end
of October craziest winner it has to be
the craziest winner chicken on a
Halloween Halloween gap because we're
metal we're so metal vampy and I will
choose the winner of the craziest the
most out-there outrageous person who
loves us the monkey to win this good
luck bye
we sound like crazy yeah well one and
only this very awesome one of a kind
this is only one one of a kind only one
and my ears are falling off what a
one-of-a-kind one Joanna there's only
one ya know okay yes only one okay
message on my hands that's why I
internets shooter she can try to eat it
this is fully off my head while I'm okay
and there's down yeah yeah College fix
your really really good because the
craziest photo op never before seen on
the entire internet